il ya 40 ans un homme qui avait été le
bel alexandre la coqueluche de paris
comme on disait alors se suicider dans
un chalet de montagne cerné par la
police
c'était stavisky escrocs alain resnais a
tiré de son histoire un film présenté à
cannes cet avis qui c'est belmondo
vous n'avez pas été au festival de
cannes depuis combien de temps
depuis vingt je crois 14 ans c'était en
60 pour me dire un peu comme d'hab il
quelle impression aviez-vous hui du
festival de cannes
mais honnêtement j'avais une impression
curieuse parce que j'étais pas disons
encore prêt connu puisque à bout de
souffle ne fait même pas sorti et alors
d'avoir mis toute cette foule cette
marée de journalistes ça m'avait un peu
surpris puisqu'il va encore plus surpris
c'est que pendant la projection les gens
s'y plaît elle restée complètement
surpris alors maintenant vous affronter
à nouveau calme oui qu'est-ce qui vous
donne ce courage ce courage et à ces
rennais parce que c'est un très beau
film et j'espère que l'ayant pas de ce
fait toute façon si on avait maintenant
je suis plus résistants sifflé que dans
ma jeunesse
d'ailleurs vous avez une double raison
d'aller au festival comme vedette
stavisky et comme coproducteur du film
c'est ça je me suis moi même envoyé au
festival en tant que producteur g
demandez à serdinya les moments de
service vous êtes un producteur assez
spécial vous ne mettez pas à jean paul
belmondo présente jean paul belmondo
dans une production de jean paul
belmondo
non j'ai ce soit ma grand-mère série
tofield un trop grand mère oui j'avais
une grand mère qui était sicilienne
s'appelait cerritos dans cette mère ma
maison de production appel série tôt
parce que quand j'étais jeune j'avais
pensé à comment me disais qu'est les
acteurs devaient changer de nom j'avais
pensé une époque à m'appeler jean-paul
cerrito alors ça serait devenu belmondo
film vous avez la réputation dans les
studios d'être un comédien qui passe son
temps à blaguer à faire des farces
comment avez-vous fait avec alain
resnais qui est un garçon très sérieux
très froid très vif je crois c'est ce
qu'on pensait ce que je pensais aussi
avant de faire le film avait creusé
rêver est un homme tout à fait normal il
aime les blagues il peux pas vous dire
qui se pend au lustre auditives ou fait
des blagues si vous chutez
automatiquement pense que vous ne faites
pas votre métier sérieusement on pense
que vous n'avez pas regardé votre rôle
si vous ne parlez pas deux heures pour
dire ah j'ai pensé quand il prend la
bonne taille humaine mais l'apprendre
comme ça veut dire si vous arrivez vous
dites c'est normalement on dit c'est pas
sérieux comme on dit souvent belmondo
s'en fout ballon hausse et avait
contracté ou de ces les choses qui
restent qui sont tes proches parce que
je pense qu'on peut et je pense pas pour
moi beaucoup d'acteurs foncier jouer la
comédie en s'amusant parce qu'avant tout
moi je joue la comédie pour m'amuser
alors en somme le belmondo pédégistes a
comme belmondo acteur il suspendra au
lustre battant que pour albert oui et
après quand vous ne pourrez plus que je
vois et puis j'espère être trouvé
l'autre fasse ici ou un moins dure